yeah welcome to this video playing blitz
King from the US try this english
defence would be six again got many
interesting games with this opening oh
yeah III it's pretty good prepare and
preventing better before ideas can i
play this may be getting for a Dutch
kind of setup yeah it's pretty normal
setup maybe maybe go for this instantly
and asking I mean what what are you
doing with this night yeah probably this
this looks like pretty decent Queens
Indian type of position the most a three
is not really helping you so much so
it's a it's fairly normally I'm not
saying why this verse or anything just
that a three is not a super helpful move
okay d66 probably preparing 97
okay we get this is interesting
interesting structure take here yeah
should I ever take on c3 g6 I wait any I
want to go to the structure anyway so i
can take your first hour wait maybe you
can move the night now could be an idea
91 or something okay didn't happen I
take both the night now what are you
doing not h4 maybe I take what the Queen
doesn't be to hanging how it is okay
they're threatening you with her with a
check so
hmm
Quinn Quinn Quinn Quinn Quinn c7 yeah
Queen f7 of course I think I said
seasons f7 of course c7 would be quite
creative wouldn't even be good you never
illegal okay so does he have any big no
bae idea to to use the pin he didn't
have any big idea so we get to this
position and this is actually quite okay
for black because this d5 pawn is
unsupported he can try for in a night 36
but this is not really leading to much
um be 5v5 you can play before maybe
let's first get this night into a good a
good spot
I go here okay if I take it now what are
you doing 95 we can take and play 97 and
it's a very very unlucky fork look d 5
octa five I could play but I can just
play here covering this and threatening
to take
he can play night at four but this is
really not not helping him much it's
still a weakness on d5 yeah preparing g5
now and at the end I hope to just take
the pawn this is the problem of this it
wants to be known upon if it doesn't
have a support from before it can easily
get lost like here which doesn't mean
it's it's anything oh cool I didn't see
that hmm Wow okay it's okay how
disappointing I was really looking
forward to play this position with an
extra bond and then I didn't get any
this is not nice like promising you some
candy and candy and then you get nothing
okay yeah rook c6 intense rook asics
attacking the airport don't you to put
back here
once or should I should i move the sea
porn actually see 5 c 3 and c se/4 and
so on source is too too ambitious I can
I could actually I could also try to go
to the second rank his weakened is a bit
with with this f3 move which isn't isn't
necessarily bad i mean he's activating
the king but this is a small idea to
activate the rook maybe you should have
he should have taken the B file instead
no I'm I'm enjoying some activity let's
just first make sure it doesn't move and
see what is what is doing I rather take
it with rook be four then with luke a3
allowing rookie to ok we go to c6
check mmm didn't see that
but but but but it's not it's not so
clear the Snyder sir is without a square
now the night is strapped which doesn't
mean it's easy to catch it but it's
something you need to to worry about
just the sepan maybe just c4 c4 c4 and
maybe 97 and so on 97 c5 g3 right slice
this is nice for black I think I'm
active pawn is not a problem what his
bones are simply doing nothing yeah
maybe a good practical decision so I
cannot really prevent prevent this last
porn from being exchanged
check
time warning
check check check check check check
check check my what what the heck is my
mouse doing man yeah well you're the
Blitz king great yeah yeah the only way
for this guy ever to win a game of chess
is probably like this but ok you can get
me some thumbs down for this for the
sentence I don't care ok yeah it was
quite interesting the same game actually
now maybe i can i can do something else
in order to to play for win here instead
of c-4 King d6 maybe or something look
at this is some this is closed this end
game I mean it is this is it's tough to
to play but on nan King g6 you can play
can play rook c3
and this intense night to see three
nights it's interesting i can i can
activate now play something like this
black is playing for when here yeah
don't know probably something like this
I've like it's just better in this
position no doubt about that I'm just
playing with additional additional
pieces alright thanks for watching